when tesla ceo elon musk first unveiled
tesla solar in 2016 the project boasted
some grand claims the tesla solar roofs
were envisioned to be stronger cheaper
and longer lasting than any other
options for generating solar power at
home currently available on the market
years on and the grand vision of tesla
solar has yet to materialize due to a
number of setbacks tesla still hasn't
had a major rollout of its solar
generating technology so far having
failed to bring sustainable energy into
the home as they have with cars given
tesla's reputation for the fast rollout
of projects this has left many wondering
what exactly went wrong here's why tesla
solar failed to take off
tesla's solar background
tesla's first foray into the world of
solar came as a result of musk's
involvement with the solar-based company
solar city solar city was first founded
in 2006 by peter and lyndon rive two
cousins of tesla ceo elon musk the
primary focus of solar city was the
door-to-door installation of solar
panels and residential homes the
business model made use of a lease
agreement in which customers paid no
upfront costs but agreed to purchase
their power from the company for 20
years this model proved popular and
became the most widespread method of
solar installation across the u.s
however despite its popularity solar
city came under fire from consumer
advocates and government regulators and
by 2016 the company was suffering under
1.5 billion u.s dollars in debt from the
beginning elon musk played a large role
in the creation of solarcity his cousins
the rive brothers actually founded
solarcity based on a suggestion from
elon himself and from the beginning the
tesla ceo served as chairman of the
company with stakes in tesla spacex and
solarcity elon musk bore an
interconnected responsibility toward the
success of all three companies so when
it looked like solarcity was heading for
bankruptcy in 2016 the tesla ceo
redirected money from spacex to buy
bonds in solarcity keeping the company
afloat until tesla could swoop in and
buy it in august of 2016. it was with
the merger of solarcity and tesla that
the first plans for tesla solar homes
began to take shape a rocky start
in many ways tesla had little option
other than to buy out solarcity as not
to have done so would most likely have
seen the forced closure of spacex
unfortunately as tesla acquired solar
city they were busy facing problems of
their own the model 3 was facing an
ongoing slew of production setbacks and
in order to get the car rolled out the
company needed to divert as much of its
resources as possible to getting the
model 3 off the ground this led to many
solar city employees being diverted away
from their work on solar projects
towards car and battery manufacturing
but these were the ones lucky enough to
keep their jobs tesla came under fire
for firing solar city employees in order
to keep operations afloat and redirected
installation teams to work on repairs
all of which slowed the rate of
residential solar installation in the
usa from 2017 this downward trend in
tesla's solar installation only worsened
leaving many questioning the venture as
a whole tesla's overall cut of the
residential solar market dropped
drastically from solarcity's peak which
once stood at around 30 percent of the
overall market and now stands at a mere
two percent production problems
in preparation for their intended wide
scale rollout of the tesla solar roofs
the company cut a deal with the state of
new york to open a mega factory in
buffalo new york the factory is
technically owned by the state of new
york and construction was completed in
2016. from its inception the facility
was intended to become a sustainable
energy powerhouse and research center in
an effort by the state to revitalize
rust belt industrial areas suffering
from industry migration in 2014
solarcity secured a deal to operate the
facility and produce solar panels the
original agreement ensured that the
operation of the facility would produce
3 000 high-tech jobs in buffalo and 5
000 state wide creating 5 billion
dollars of economic activity these
promises caused the state to award the
facility an additional 750 million
dollars in incentives however as tesla
took over the operation of the buffalo
facility in 2017 it was clear that the
original promises made during the
acquisition would not be fulfilled in
2018 tesla committed to creating roughly
1400 high-tech jobs at the facility by
2020 due to a number of setbacks
including the covet 19 pandemic
production had to be scaled down
numerous times and in 2021 tesla
received yet another extension to their
agreement should they fail to secure
1400 jobs in the facility by the end of
the year they could face tens of
millions of dollars in fines to the
state of new york as the state of new
york essentially built and equipped this
factory for free in exchange for
promises of job security and
productivity many parties have been
disappointed by the lack of follow
through that the gigan new york plant
has produced not only have the proposed
job targets not been met but tesla is
reported to have outsourced their solar
panel production to china instead of the
domestic production that was promised to
take place in buffalo all these issues
regarding the solvency of the buffalo
plant have played a major role in
slowing the large-scale rollout of tesla
solar and until the buffalo plant can
reach its targets it's unlikely that the
project will be able to materialize on a
scale that will allow the solar roofs to
be both accessible and affordable
unrealistic promises straight away when
elon musk took to the stage to announce
tesla's master plan for producing solar
paneled roofs doubts began to surface
the designs that musk showcased were
noteworthy for their strikingly
different appearances from traditional
solar panels rather than the
traditionally large photovoltaic panel
that most people are used to musk
unveiled the design for a series of
photovoltaic shingles this would allow
customers to have their entire roofs
constructed out of solar panels and
still look exactly like conventional
roof tiling in practice this would allow
for the ability to harvest far greater
amounts of energy than traditional
residential solar panels while all of
this sounded and looked great the issue
was that the photovoltaic tiles
showcased by musk were not yet
functional the tiles used for the
unveiling were just design samples and
tesla had yet to even develop a working
prototype with the technology itself
still in early development a lot of the
hype surrounding the solar roof quickly
fell flat industry experts in particular
were highly skeptical of the
technological promises being made by
tesla the technology necessary for the
kind of photovoltaic tiles tesla
promised in 2016 is notoriously tricky
to get right and previous attempts to do
so were abandoned due to the lack of
economic viability tesla ceo elon musk
has admitted that many of the promises
made as part of the solar roof
initiative were unrealistic as the
company underestimated the difficulty of
the technology and the amount of
personalization that each installation
would require with both tesla and spacex
projects ramping up in intensity over
the previous few years musk has
increasingly been forced to turn to
third-party contractors to take care of
all current tesla solar installations
however finally getting a tesla solar
unit installed can be just the beginning
of the problems for residential
customers customer complaints
while tesla solar may not have entered
widespread rollout as planned they do
still service a large number of people
the solar tiled roof only makes up a
tiny fraction of tesla solar's
installations numbering in the hundreds
the vast majority of their solar
customers still possess traditional
solar panels the company has installed
over 200 000 of its power wall solar
power generators around the world but
things have proven to be anything but
smooth sailing for many of these
customers tesla has come under fire a
number of times for supposed price hikes
in their services many customers
reported being given a quote only for
the quote to increase come the time of
installation several lawsuits were
launched toward the company for these
supposed price hikes which prompted
tesla to announce that they would
reverse the price increases in question
beyond that the quality of customer
service offered to tesla solar clients
has a setback for many customers
regularly report experiencing bugs and
dead ends on the tesla app which is
designed for monitoring the tesla solar
system's energy production and usage as
well as for scheduling maintenance and
repairs the tesla solar hotlines have
become notorious for seemingly infinite
wait times and many customers report
that the overall process of installing
tesla solar was far more lengthy and
expensive than they were promised at the
outset these hiccups in customer service
have led to bad press which has left
many skeptical toward tesla solar and
slowed its widespread growth even
further the path forward
with all these production setbacks and
customer complaints many have been left
wondering what the future holds in store
for tesla's grand plan to bring
sustainable energy production to as many
residential homes as possible well in
response elon musk has begun devoting an
increase in manpower to the development
of solar glass a key new technology that
could help in the widespread use of
solar energy production what's more
tesla is focusing more resources into
improving the efficiency of its roof
units as well as constantly improving
the efficiency of its power walls these
powerwall units are essentially giant
battery storage units and as they
improve in efficiency they are likely to
incentivize more and more customers and
businesses to go off the main power grid
and adopt solar power although tesla
solar has faced many setbacks ceo elon
musk is still determined to explore all
the possibilities of solar energy and
continues to pursue his goal of bringing
sustainable energy to all and despite
the setbacks with food production long
distance travel and even space
exploration all making use of solar
power technology tesla solar may very
well have a bright future